life down here slowing once more the
country going back
into hibernation schools just until
mid-february at the earliest
remaining non-essential shops across
england shut
stay at home is the instruction once
again in law
the prime minister's fourth address to
the nation for the first time doing it
live
and his hardest so far since the
pandemic began last year
the whole united kingdom has been
engaged in a great
national effort to fight covid and
there's no doubt that in
fighting the old variant of the virus
our collective efforts
were working and would have continued to
work
but we now have a new variant of the
virus and it's been both
frustrating and alarming to see the
speed
with which the new variant is spreading
as i speak to you tonight
our hospitals are under more pressure
from
than at any time since the start of the
pandemic
in england alone the number of covered
patients in hospitals has increased
by nearly a third in the last week to
almost 27
000 and that number is 40 percent higher
than the first peak with most of the
country already under extreme measures
it's clear that we need to do more
together to bring this new variant under
control
while our vaccines are rolled out
in england we must therefore go into a
national lockdown
which is tough enough to contain this
variant
that means the government is once again
instructing you to stay at home
today the united kingdom's chief medical
officers have advised that the country
should move to alert level 5
meaning that if action is not taken
nhs capacity may be overwhelmed
within 21 days having visited a north
london hospital
earlier in the day he told the nation he
hoped that vaccinating the vulnerable
that 13 million people getting jabs
starts to get us out of this
of course there's one huge difference
compared to last year
we're now rolling out the biggest
vaccination program
in our history so far we
in the uk have vaccinated more people
than in the rest of europe combined with
the arrival today of the uk's own oxford
astrazeneca vaccine the pace of
vaccination
is accelerating if deaths start to fall
as the vaccine takes effect and
critically
if everyone plays their part
by following the rules then i hope we
can steadily move
out of lockdown reopening schools after
the february half term
and starting cautiously to move regions
down the tiers
by the middle of february if things go
well
and with a fair wind in our sails we
expect to have offered the first vaccine
dose to everyone
in the four top priority groups i want
to say
to everyone right across the uk
that i know how tough this is and i know
how frustrated you are and i know that
you've had
more than enough of government guidance
about defeating this virus
but now more than ever we must
pull together the weeks ahead will be
the hardest yet
but i really do believe that we're
entering the last
phase of the struggle because with every
jab
that goes into our arms we are tilting
the odds
against kovid and in favor
of the british people and thanks to the
miracle
of science not only is the end in sight
but we know exactly how we will get
there
opposition leaders including this one
spent the day calling for the prime
minister to act the way he did
the really important thing is to say
that we support these measures and
we're all under a duty i think to do
whatever we can to make them work
whatever other quarrels i may have with
the prime minister i think tonight
what the country wants to see is people
pulling together
to say that we have to follow these new
rules
we have to make this work these are
going to be really really tough weeks
the important thing about tonight's
announcement wasn't so much the detail
of the new restrictions there was a grim
inevitability about those it was the
difficult process of looking for hints
of light about when this new lockdown in
england might end
now boris johnson did say that maybe
children could go back to school after
the mid-february half term
but he did so with a striking lack of
conviction which is
quite a change for him
a nation rewinds 10 months and restores
the toughest coronavirus rules
but the scars of the first two spikes
and first two lockdowns remain
as yet unhealed making tonight the
hardest yet
sam coates sky news